[Music]
doing it practice good no tell it before
yeah [ __ ] I think I've got an advantage
on this one yeah success alright for
this challenge you seen this before yeah
I think I seen it before we Asian I've
seen this I think I saw Jackie Chan do
it once on like behind the scenes of
rush hour or some other and where he put
some coins on the back of his hand
and the challenge was to flick all the
coins up in the air and grab each one
with a different grasp of the hand so
pretty much like this
right that was - right Alex challenge
for today is to do three coins and the
losers forfeit is to have a heavy object
logged into the side of their head to
hunt philemon the skull inside the face
alright yeah yeah yeah sure
so first person to do it with
ready
it's gonna be embarrassing
alright okay I guess I'm ready
that was pretty fast I just left the way
you caught one got the other punch the
other one and then he went mom's ahead
like you let look at that so I realized
that punched it until I'd already go
into the ground
[Music]
call I do that one
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
you
you
[Music]